three minutes of feedback and change
your business if you think about it
smartly I don't hear this I don't have
time as the boss you have time go
[ __ ] execute
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you ever done young talk to text and
stuff it's really good right okay what I
open - especially with headphones now
what teach me you just click oh this you
mean no oh this thing right and it's
actually really solid we practice
something like it really is right how
was your birthday claw do you guys see
the video that Club got from my kids no
good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
entire hiding who gets to move so slides
at the end X what right yeah quick Dave
- Jenna - oh yeah like oh I'm an idea
yeah can you change this whole section
to have more seats than it has now
so it could become the new preview - how
many sinks I think we should actually
have in this company so what I know we
talked about that before you need like
just adding can you can you slow this
out out right so let's let's what yeah
stick with me let me play a game with
you real quick ready so right now this
seats two four six eight right yes I
wanted to see 12 and then blow the whole
thing out done we have to do it anyway
because that's what's gonna happen how
are you gonna fit 12 desks here no not
one bit
oh yeah well going on you would have
people share Adele oh there's way too
much members way too much room here this
is there's like just way too much room
here this is all gonna be my kind of
characters anyway so they're not going
to be all bad damaged I mean there's
wait there's six [ __ ] people in a
held a lot less space there than there
is 12 here their desks
I don't same width as each of these
desks 48 inches is the width of all visa
great make make anybody associated
directly with me get comfortable 36
inches [ __ ] squeeze everybody by next
and David you how many inches is yet how
many inches do you need of deafspace
Danny Davis more how much 16 my man no
no he's getting 16 and then we'll figure
out the rest
so here's what why you do ASAP are you
set get rid of this and standing desk it
I want to see how many I can actually
fit because I have a funny feeling I can
do maybe three rows of it like there's
some stuff running through my life let's
get me a proper standing death situation
here alright sky you ready for the
tweets yes good green shirt bun right
joke
alright we're putting standing desks
we're doing a standing desk situation if
you're a standing desk creator or
manufacturer I don't know what the hell
the world is word is hit up sky we're
look at the deals it was the only video
good deals we like good deals
[Music]
if you're a manager a leader CEO c-suite
if you're running [ __ ]
three minutes to make an impact on your
business
I hope you caught that whole thing run
it from the beginning right now listen I
want to grab you for three minutes go
literally 100 seconds to tell you that
you were absolutely crushing it bro and
the feedback is all the way through
awesome and you're really putting
yourself in a position to be very
successful you're awesome
I think you're capturing it yeah and I'm
gonna push us there go and you should
keep following your instincts and also
and energy and I'm just impressed
good great for sure then sit man my
inbox is open keeping your thing but I
need you to have that your pocket three
I appreciate it my pleasure man I'm
going taxes no worries man no worries
you too
good to see ya good how are you what's
cookin ah looks good
thank you Indian you're listening
it's a big ass deal yeah yeah listen I
uh say you're probably wondering why I'm
calling you in yeah I'm calling you in
for a very good reason you're doing
exceptionally well and very much look
the part of what I'm trying to build
around here and I wanted you to know
that for me oh thank you yeah I'm really
happy with your work I think the company
is seeing it at the highest levels and I
think you're really putting yourself in
a great position and I really just want
to take this one minute to a give you a
good day and I'm sure it's fun to hear a
but B for you to also know that you've
direct access to me if there's anything
I could be a help of any ideas you have
any thoughts you have any needs you have
I really want you to use me as an asset
and I'm just really impressed with your
work oh thank you
follow your instincts on this like like
just keep doing what you're doing don't
know don't overthink this meeting and I
just keep doing what you're doing
all right well okay let me top you yeah
I mean you always say that like you
never know people don't people don't
believe it yeah so I keep trying to hack
it and so whether it's negative
reinforcement positive reinforcement
winking of people grabbing them at
parties and saying hello or the most fun
something like this and saying hey not
only is this good feedback this is
really good feedback and worth me taking
some my time out to tell you that to
your face you should take advantage of
that okay holy cool awesome yeah
again and I got things for two as well
keep up the good work yeah I mean it
three minutes of feedback can change
your business if you think about it
smartly I don't hear this I don't have
time as the boss you have time go
[ __ ] execute go ready go hey guys
it's me really sort of step up on my
podcast and can do some contexts and
pretext to some of these talks because
the talk I gave the other day to a
incubator around logistics a bunch of
startup founders in Chattanooga
Tennessee tennis team they're at dynamo
and and lightpost
real great partners friends just people
I enjoy down in Chattanooga and they've
got this incubator around logistics
companies and I just kind of gave in and
shot my [ __ ] and the energy of the room
and and the moment in time I think
created a really good piece of content
and so I know you're running on the
treadmill right now or walking the dog
or driving into work so I know that
you're possibly consuming this at times
so for everybody who kind of passively
consumes pay triple attention
this one's deep it's got this has some
[ __ ] your rewrite totally this is some
[ __ ] listen to some [ __ ] enjoy this
episode all right man i enjoying this
apart
good for ya cool man look at sort of
sitting down and get to know you better
shishun so man I'm PI I knew I'd get to
see I wasn't planning on being here
today not everything but to the seal
yeah good feel free to call in a favor
to him but because I was telling you
doing I created this podcast force a
friend it maintains relationships you
know it's important yeah I highly
recommend it yeah good to see about help
you said you're high
[Music]
have you been able to gather any Intel
yet I know that we kind of moved quickly
for this like literally I'm like I want
to like set up a call or two I just want
to talk about I want to talk about some
framework you know hey everybody look
like just want to talk shoots is in the
house running the four DS program he
stole it from me
may takes it very personally they have a
huge rivalry but I just wanted to get on
and scream live as were kind of wrapping
I'm kind of wrapping up so many of you I
mean basically I've only been promoting
this through Instagram live so many of
you guys know about the four DS daily
digital deep dive the one day consulting
product at vaynermedia cells that has
been going once you give them how many
we done are the media strategy thing has
been big writable you so honestly as a
lot of you guys know the biggest thing
that I've been stunned about is people
who follow me so I mean look if you're
spending $10,000 for the product and
flying to New York you're like into my
thesis you this has only been done
through ensuing live like some of you in
here right now by the way if you've gone
to a four D and you're in here right now
make that known and give and give the
honest feedback go listen to [ __ ]
shoot some in here and uh but the media
thing has been real the clawed thing the
media the culture and the media thing
had been the kraang's right and energy
like understanding how do you have you
come up with how you understand what
your North Star is what were unifying
message is and then how do you go off
the strategy that allows you to create a
little piece of content that's right for
the right platform that what platform
should you be on how do you know where
your target is or where your leads are
coming from we are picking the final
date of four DS that I'm guaranteed to
be in so as we start promoting this as
vaynermedia we're not going to make the
guarantee of me and so I'm just kind of
like giving one last at-bat so maybe
what's the punchline
mate once this is open June 8th is open
your book or your guarantee of both of
those we have some types of July will
open more in Juneau
can't guarantee universe all right so
one more time nasally the June 8
brochure alright guys so so if you look
down here for DS at vaynermedia if you
want to be part of one of the first six
or seven inaugural event for DS if it's
a full day here at vaynermedia New York
City 10 hours consulting session the
community now we're putting people in a
private Facebook group as well that's
interesting yeah something conversation
went on of the the community is really
getting better viewing each other after
the day to talk to Rose challenging
business relevant seller each other
successes stay in touch a couple of
deals are being done so I may 25th June
II get to New York City one hour with me
with group and so hope you guys hope you
guys enjoy it and join it and sup guys 6
p.m. indie rock heading to the to the
airport and trying to make this flight
we might be late again but and excite
about today a lot done in a very short
window happy birthday mom
very much that's most important tonight
and escape like this nice feeling dear
ox job as we're walking through anyway
the airport hustling got to do a new
intro to daily buddy working on that
little eight six eight seconds little
stinging back Heathrow
[Music]